like again I would like to introduce the
next speaker and Matt line Berkeley
professor all right thanks so like some
of the earlier talks today I'm gonna
focus on mechanism design challenges for
crypto currencies so let me just give
one slide repeating some of the themes
from Tim's talk earlier of like what the
talk is not about and what it is about
so I'm not gonna discuss anything about
cryptographic or network security and
I'm not gonna discuss what I'm gonna
think of as like malicious attacks or
give like a quick distinction at the end
of the slide exactly what I mean by that
and what I am going to focus on instead
are thinking of you know crypto
currencies there are mechanisms in the
sense that you propose a protocol and
you would like people to follow that
protocol but you cannot force them to
follow that protocol okay
and representative distinction to have
in mind of what isn't is not the focus
of this talk so if you're familiar with
selfish mining things like selfish
mining are the focus of this talk
because selfish mining improves the
rewards that you get it's a strategic
thing to do it does not directly attack
consensus so if someone is selfish
mining it does not immediately violate
the consistency in life nests of course
it's a long-term concern for consensus
if someone can get too much rewards
versus something like double spending I
would say directly at axe consensus and
I'm not going to be considering attacks
like double spending throughout this
talk okay so that's a distinction to
have in mind
okay and so using Bitcoin as an example
I just want to again go through what our
deviations from a protocol that you can
and can't do right so I'm not thinking
about people who are going to break
Creek top or break cryptography or find
hash collisions and again like these
aspects of the protocol are pretty well
done and what I am going to consider
again using Bitcoin as an example is
that Bitcoin says I would like you to
follow the longest chain protocol you
don't have to do that you can point to
any other block you want the protocol
says that I would like you to once you
find a block broadcasted immediately you
don't have to do that nothing about the
protocol can force you to do that and
again the protocol says I would like you
to include perhaps the most valuable
transactions I would like you to fill a
block as much as possible but the
protocol can't force you to do that okay
and the idea behind these are that you
know there is no way that cryptography
can possibly solve these problems the
only way that you're going to solve
these problems is you need to
incentivize people to follow the
protocol okay and then one more reminder
so I'm not going to consider deviations
like Eclipse attacks or network
partitioning attacks or anything else
like that and again the goal of this
talk is just to isolate the strategic
aspect so it's very possible for some of
the things I'm talking about you might
say that models unrealistic because
here's an attack I could do on it and I
would say that's fine I'm just not
concerned about that right now I only
want to focus on people trying to make
extra revenue
okay so what I want to do in this talk
is I'm going to think of it more as an
overview rather than focusing on one
specific result and of course overview
is biased towards my own research so
here are just I'm not gonna read through
all the topics but I'll just leave it on
the screen while I'm talking
so these are some representative topics
that I'm going to cover and again the
theme is through all of these I'm gonna
try and show you ways in which say
existing protocols are not incentivizing
people to follow them and discuss the
issues that come up there okay so the
first thing I want to do is I just want
to formally define a game related to in
this case the Bitcoin protocol okay and
what that will do is that will formally
set up what are the actions the players
can take the action slot strategies that
players can use what are the payoffs
that they get for different behavior and
then it's meaningful to ask questions
such as what is an equilibrium
what would strategic buyers do and stuff
like this okay
so here's the setup so hopefully you
will look at this and you will think of
this as just a simplification of what
happens in Bitcoin mining okay so in the
setup I'm just going to say that there's
a set of miners every miner has some
mining power and the sum of the mining
powers is equal to one and at all times
every miner is aware of some directed
tree you can think of that you know the
nodes in the tree are the blocks and
they're pointing backwards or their
predecessor and they all share a common
root and the only thing I want to
emphasize in the model is that you know
I said that a miner is aware of a
directed tree so by this I mean that
they have heard announced some blocks
and there are some blocks and maybe they
haven't heard announced and so that's
not in their tree okay so what happens
in the game so every time step a random
miner is selected to mine a block
proportional to their mining power what
does it mean to mine a block you create
a new node and you get to add a directed
edge to any single node among the blocks
you've heard about and the second thing
you can do in every time step is you can
choose to broadcast any nodes and when
you broadcast you're just going to add
it to the nodes that every other miner
has heard about okay and I just want to
emphasize right the idea is that there's
nothing in the Bitcoin software that
forces you to mind on top of the longest
chain you can
on top of any block you want but of
course it has to be a note that you've
heard about you need to know the hash
okay so what are the payoffs in the game
the payoffs in this game is going to be
the limit as a number of steps
approaches infinity of the fraction of
blocks that you create in the longest
chain okay so this is a formally
specified game and I'm going to go
through sort of like what are the
assumptions I made in defining this game
quickly and after I go through that if
there are any questions I'll take
questions on sort of like why I like
this model and why not okay so what I
want to point out is it right so I just
said that there's this thing called a
time step it's a discrete unit and I
said every time step someone creates a
block okay so that doesn't sound like
what happens in real Bitcoin in real
Bitcoin the blocks commit an exponential
rate and what I want to you know say so
this is abstracting that away I'm just
saying what I really care about is when
the block arrives who created it what I
don't care about is exactly what
physical time that block arrived okay
the other thing I said was I said
there's one type of action called
broadcast right and I said when you
broadcast everyone immediately hears
about it and everyone hears about it
okay so this is abstracting away things
that I know matter a lot for network
security like point the fact that
sometimes communication is
point-to-point and sometimes there's
latency okay but I'm saying for the
strategic aspects this is actually not
going to be that critical so I
abstracted that away too
okay and then in defining the payoffs I
chose to say the fraction of blocks that
you make in the longest chain that
that's I decided was the important part
and what I want to point out is that
this assumes that the players are trying
to maximize their reward denominated in
Bitcoin per unit time okay and the
reason for this is you can think of
because of the difficulty adjustment the
longest chain
it grows proportionally to time okay so
when you maximize your fraction of
blocks in the longest chain that is
actually maximizing the reward you get
per growth of the longest chain which is
the same thing as a reward you get per
unit of time okay so okay one more slide
and then if there are questions on the
model I'll take those so I said that the
first assumption I kind of abstracted
away the fact that it takes X you know
that the blocks arrive at an exponential
rate and I think this is a nice aspect
about the model because it makes the
math simpler and I don't believe that
this affects any of the qualitative
conclusions that you would draw with
respect to the incentives at all so I
think this is a good thing to do okay
similarly I said to be abstracted away
all of the hard aspects of communication
I just said when you broadcast its
immediate everyone hears about it and
again this makes a model and math in
this case drastically more transparent
and simple and again for the strategic
aspects I don't think this affects the
conclusions you would draw draw at all
so I again think this is a good thing to
do the last assumption is different okay
so for the last assumption I said this
assumes that the players are trying to
maximize their Bitcoin per unit time it
also assumes that they're paid through a
block reward and at the transaction fees
are zero okay so this I think is
different than the first two this is not
just mathematically simplifying this is
actually saying something about the
system okay so it assumes for instance
that the exchange rate between US
dollars and Bitcoin is what economists
would call exogenously it does not
affect the US dollar to a Bitcoin
exchange rate that you want to actually
maximize the number of Bitcoin you get
it also assumes that the block reward
dominates the transaction fees and that
people are really trying to maximize the
amount of block rewards they get not the
transaction fees okay and so what I just
want to point out about assumptions like
this is
I think it is consistent to believe both
of the following so first I believe that
it is valuable to derive results under
these assumptions because it gives you
good insight into the block reward model
and into settings where maybe you are
genuinely trying to maximize the Bitcoin
you get and I also believe that future
work should examine these aspects
separately so one of the results I'm
gonna tell you later on is gonna change
the model to look at transaction fees
instead of the block reward okay so now
let me pause are there any questions
just about the way that I set up the
model okay so that's another one I would
say they could have could have gone into
this I think that's a reason that's a
reasonable assumption that I also would
be I think would be interesting to
consider and in this model I chose not
to consider that I would think of that
as just an arbitrary decision you could
consider it or not I think both would be
interesting
alright ok so again just to get a little
bit more comfort with this model so what
does the longest chain protocol sound
like in this language so one thing that
I think is nice is that this is a
complete description of the longest
chain protocol in this game it's three
english sentences right so what does it
ask you to do whenever you're selected
to build a block you should point to the
furthest node from the root among stuff
you've heard about when you need to
break ties you should break ties in
favor of the first note that you heard
about and again because I assume that
communication is discrete there may
actually be a genuine tie in the first
note that you heard about so if there is
one then you should still write just do
it randomly and you should just always
broadcast everything that you've heard
about every single round okay so this is
the longest chain protocol okay so all
the way back in nakamoto's whitepaper so
he obviously would not have used this
exact language to say it but I think the
following intuition was conveyed which
was that if all other mod miners are
following the longest chain protocol and
you have less than 50% of the
computational power in the network then
your best response in this game is to
also follow the longest chain protocol
okay so I think this is I would say
mapped on to this game what people mean
when they say that it's um you know
secure unless someone has 51% of the
computational power okay and then you
know I think hopefully everyone
remembers the intuition for this the
intuition was it right if the rest of
network is more powerful than you then
there is a specific attack that does not
work okay and that specific attack is
you cannot just try to build your own
separate chain because if you do that
then eventually the 51% is going to
outpace the 49% and you're not going to
create the longest chain okay so the the
intuition in some sense was you know
correct in the sense that there is a
specific attack that is not a better
response and following the protocol but
it does not mean that there's nothing
you can do it's better okay and so so
there's a big result in 2014 and this is
actually kind of roughly what got me
interested in crypto currencies was
realizations like this okay and so the
theorem is it actually in this game if
you have more than a third of the
computational power it
actually not a best response to follow
the longest chain protocol even when
everything everyone else is following
the longest chain okay and this is the
selfish mining attack I don't know if
everyone knows exactly what the attack
is I'm not gonna go through all of the
details but the intuition for the attack
is important for some of the stuff that
I'm gonna say later so the main
intuition is the following so when you
create a block you should hide it
instead of immediately broadcasting it
and so what does this do so one thing
that might happen is maybe you get lucky
and you happen to mine two rounds in a
row now what happens if you mine two
rounds in a row now the next person who
mines is not gonna know that you have a
private chain of length two longer than
the current current longest chain and
they're gonna mine in the wrong place
and that block is gonna be wasted okay
and that's good for you because that's
less blocks on the longest chain and so
you will have a greater fraction of
blocks on the longest chain the other
thing that might happen is maybe you get
unlucky and maybe you don't mind in the
next round and if you don't mind in the
next round then you run the risk of
losing this block that you just hid and
that's bad that cost you a block in the
longest chain that you otherwise would
have had okay so there's a you know
there's a risk and reward and it turns
out that if you have enough
computational power a third is the magic
number then the expected gain outweighs
the expected loss and this is strictly
profitable for you to do
okay the other theorem became one of
these papers is a TC I forget where the
other one was published but they came
two years later and what they said is it
yes
selfish mining is a problem because the
magic number is not 50% it's 33% but it
turns out that for the same game that if
everyone has less than the number is
roughly 30% of the mining power then
longest chain actually is a best
response to all of their miners using
longest chain so that means is that
unless there is sufficiently large
miners it is a Nash equilibrium for
everyone to follow the protocol okay so
the takeaway I would say from this line
of works is that yes you should be
concerned about large miners not
necessarily 50% miners but if you really
believe that the system is filled with
very small miners then the block reward
model and with proof of work seems to be
incentive compatible for people to
follow a longest chain yeah sure so I
formally specified a game and so that
game said that your payoff is equal to
the fraction of blocks that you get on
the longest chain and so now that I
formally specified a game I literally
just mean if everyone else is using
longest chain your best response is to
also use longest chain and so therefore
everyone using longest chain is a Nash
equilibrium sure yeah yeah so I guess
what I mean by that is
let me take like a minute to think about
it offline my gut reaction is that it
should be like it's not a finite horizon
game so sub game perfect doesn't make
sense but it should be that you know it
should have all those properties but I
don't wanna I want to take another
minute to think about that yeah what the
Nash equilibrium is it no I don't
believe and yet the system is secure I
mean nakamoto secure do we know
because if - selfish - fight each other
that's going to be the outcome so I know
a time I'd know better I don't believe
that there's like a closed-form solution
for the equilibrium ok so there's so
just repeating there was a recent paper
that did find the closed form
equilibrium for two competing strategic
miners there was a follow-up to your
question that I didn't quite understand
in that case an approximation
because approximately yes we know a Nash
equilibrium in the case when there's
more than one strategic minor the other
thing I would say even when there's one
strategic minor I'm not saying that
everyone following longest chain and one
person selfish mining I'm not saying
that's a Nash equilibrium
so I would say okay there are two
separate questions though which was what
happens when there's two and what
happens when there's only one and so I
think the claim is that even when
there's two you now know an equilibrium
whereas it wasn't obvious and we knew
the equilibrium when there was one
either
okay okay so let me just give now kind
of like a taste of why I think you know
this research and everything I'm gonna
talk about afterwards is important right
so my understanding of reality is it
selfish mining has not been detected on
Bitcoin but it has been detected on alt
coins and kind of the goal of the you
know the research and I'm gonna talk
about is to just be able to answer why
okay so I'm not interested in sort of
like very quantitative answers to be
able to say precisely for Bitcoin this
is exactly why but I would like to have
qualitative understandings of why for
one coin it happens in another coin it
doesn't okay
the obvious answer might just be that
there's no single miner that has more
than 30% of the power and this is not
the selfish mining is not the kind of
attack that you can safely do
undetectably with a mining pool you
would need to actually own 30% of the
hardware another another reason that I
actually buy is that maybe it's because
the exchange rate is not exogenous so
maybe it's the case that if you were too
selfish mine yeah you would make more
Bitcoin but maybe those Bitcoin would
turn into less US dollars and maybe
that's why right now it doesn't work the
only thing I would say in response to
that is that I would ask okay so what
would happen if it was possible for a
large miner to also short sell Bitcoin
and then I would say okay so now maybe
you don't care so much if you hurt the
exchange rate of Bitcoin maybe that's
even better for you if you can do that
and currently my understanding is that
it is impossible to short sell large
amounts of Bitcoin but that might be
something that changes in the future so
I'm trying to say is basically just like
it's important to understand things like
selfish mining even if we're not seeing
them right now on Bitcoin we should
understand why are we not seeing them
right now on Bitcoin and what might
change to cause it to become profitable
on Bitcoin or some other cryptocurrency
that matters
ok so now I'm going to transition into
talking about some more of my own work
so this paper has actually been around
for a while so this is from 2016 but
what it looks at is the difference
between transaction fees and the block
reward
okay so currently in Bitcoin that
transaction fees are low and everything
I talked about before us
you know actually assumes that
transaction fees are not just low it
assumes that they're zero and I think
that's a reasonable approximation to the
state of affairs that we were trying to
model okay but everyone knows every four
years the block reward halves and
eventually is going to be zero and the
hope is it transaction fees will take
over and so there's this hotly debated
topic which is what is the right way -
excuse me make sure that transaction
fees rise and are stable okay and this
is one of the aspects of the block size
debate and what I want to point out
though is a kind of prior to our paper
there was not a lot of debate about the
following and it was kind of just
assumed that like okay look if the
miners are risk neutral and it's the
case that you somehow get transaction
fees to rise and become stable and
become exactly equal to the block reward
and expectation then it really shouldn't
matter whether you're rewarded in twelve
and a half Bitcoin deterministically
through a block reward or whether you're
rewarded 12 and a half in expectation
through stable continuous transaction
fees okay and part of that is even true
it's the case that if everyone is using
exactly the same strategies and everyone
is risk neutral no one really cares
whether they're being paid
twelve-and-a-half deterministically or
twelve and a half an expectation okay
and the in informal theorem from this
paper is that this is kind of very much
not true and incentive issues with
transaction fees are way more complex
than with the block reward even with
risk neutral miners even when the
transaction fees are stable and let me
for now focus on this because this is a
concrete theorem statement which is it
there is a selfish mining attack and
that attack is profitable
no matter your computational power okay
so even if you have less than 1% of the
computational power there is a selfish
mining attack you can do that is better
than being honest and just again
contrast this with the blocker
word setting where if you had less than
30 percent then there's no selfish
mining attack that is profitable okay
and the intuition to have I'll give you
a little bit more intuition on the next
slides is that there is a way richer
strategy space and now you can use a
strategy that depends on the number of
fees that are included in blocks and so
yes it's the case that if you use
strategies that you could have used in
the original setting you're gonna get
the same an expectation but there's just
now richer ways that you can try to
deviate from the intended protocol okay
so what I would like to do again just in
the interest of being formal I would
just like to tell you what the model is
but this time I don't want to dwell on
it too much but I just want to show you
how you can still do something simple
that sounds like the block reward one
okay so just like before everyone has a
hash power everyone's aware of a
directed graph and now since there are
transaction fees in the system I just
won't say how do i model that so this is
what I mean by continuous and stable is
it for any interval from zero to T a
total of T transaction fees have arrived
they're infinitesimally small and
everything is continuous okay so now I
would say for this game it actually does
matter the arrival time of the blocks
because that's gonna determine how many
fees you can include or how many fees
have arrived since the last block so
according to a poisson clock with rate
one a miner is gonna be selected to mine
a block again proportional to their hash
power what do you do when you mind a
block you create a new node point to
anything that you've heard of and now
what's the other decision you get to
make you get to decide how many fees you
want to include okay so what's the only
constraint well you can't include fees
that have been in previous blocks so it
better be the case that if you're mining
a block at time T it better be the case
that the sum of all fees included in you
and everything before you that some of
those fees better be less than or equal
to T okay and again you can broadcast
like before and the payoffs are now
going to be again as the time goes to
infinity the amount of fees you have in
the longest chain at time T divided by
T's is again trying to amortize you know
so now capital T actually has something
to do with physical time and it's trying
to say what is the rate at which you are
earning money
okay so this is just again I want to
think of this more as just an proof of
concept that you can make a simple
sounding formal model for transaction
fees that captures the transaction fees
issues
okay so I would like to do now is give
you intuition for what's different
between transaction fees in the block
reward model so the first thing I would
like to do is again just remind you what
is longest chains exactly the same as
before
but we ask that you include the maximum
available fees because that's what
you're supposed to do okay so let's say
that somehow you find yourself in this
situation so there was a fork that just
happened you know happened naturally and
it happened to be the case that you
heard about this block first so you
heard about a first before B and for
some reason it happened to be the case
that this block included more fees than
this one okay so you've heard about
these two blocks and if you are
following the longest chain protocol in
earnest you are supposed to tiebreak in
favor of the one that you heard about
first and so you're going to create this
block that includes all available fees
and that's going to be five
okay so something else you could do you
could just like barely deviate from the
longest chain protocol you can say the
only thing I'm gonna do differently is
I'm just gonna tie break differently
I will never mind on top of something
that is not longest chain but I'm just
gonna be a little bit eager and I'm
going to break ties in favor of
whichever one will let me include the
most fees okay so in this case what you
would do instead is you would say well
instead of making a block worth five
here I'll make a block worth ten here
okay
so that doesn't seem like a huge deal
it's it's it's really just a difference
in tiebreaking and if everyone is using
this you will still have a pretty
functional longest chain protocol the
problem now comes is what if you're in
this situation and you'd think or you
know that the other miners are using
this petty or eager tie breaking rule so
now what you could do is you could
follow the longest chain and you can
make your block that's worth five and
you'll definitely get at most five by
doing that because that's the number of
fees that remain and another thing you
could do is you can instead decide to
not follow any you know the longest
chain protocol at all this is no longer
just different tie breaking you created
a new block that creates this situation
that the previous miners saw and now
this block is worth ten you know if the
next miner chooses to do this petty
tiebreaking and get ten for themselves
instead of getting five for themselves
okay so okay so there's a realistic you
know there's a reasonable question to
ask like should you expect in this
setting should people you know tie break
in this petty way or do I think they
would still follow the longest chain you
know the longest chain verbatim I don't
know it seems reasonable to me to expect
that at least a decent fraction of the
network would probably tie break in this
way because it's still fairly honest and
you're just getting extra rewards by tie
breaking by doing so
okay so that's kind of intuition for why
there's a richer strategy space and I
just want to point out that like this
whole situation this makes no sense in
the block reward model right so in the
block reward model this number is the
same as this number is the same as this
number and it doesn't make sense to try
and like you know cause this fork just
so that you can get a block that's worth
the same as your block that was over
here right so there's only makes sense
because of transaction fees okay and the
same intuition is going to show up I
just want to give you one slide of
intuition for why is selfish mining
profitable no matter you're a
computational power in the transaction
fees model okay so I want to repeat the
main ideas for selfish mining right we
said that when you create a block you're
gonna hide it and the one new idea is
I'm gonna say only hide blocks that have
very low fees in them okay so if you
happen to create a block and there's
just not a lot of fees use it to selfish
mine if you happen to create a block and
there's a lot of fees don't use it too
selfish mine just publish it immediately
as normal okay
the reasoning is the same if you get
lucky and you mind two rounds in a row
you can use these to cancel others if
you get unlucky and you don't mind next
round you might lose the hidden block
here's kind of the again the only key
idea is you know who cares if you only
hid blocks that were worth very little
then it doesn't really cost you that
much to just lose them so you might as
well try to selfish mine and get lucky
and basically the idea is that there's a
sufficiently small cut off that you will
mine blocks with that few fees with
nonzero probability even if you have 1%
or less than 1% of the total hash power
okay so the main takeaway from this
section I would say is it just because a
protocol appears incentive compatible
with the block reward don't assume it's
gonna stay that way with transaction
fees even if everyone is risk neutral
even if everything is continuous and
stable and the other thing I want to
highlight is I like thinking of selfish
mining as being a lens that we used to
uncover this issue right so I'm not
necessarily claiming that I think the
attack that is going to cause problems
is selfish mining but I would say that
we use selfish mining as a lens to learn
that even small miners might be able to
gain the rewards when transaction fees
matter instead of block rewards okay so
there any questions so I'm gonna
transition to something a little bit
different if anyone has questions just
feel free to ask alright so the next
thing I want to talk about is um proof
of stake so we heard from a couple
people earlier I'll just you know here's
a different slide illustrating the same
point which is just that Bitcoin uses a
lot of electricity you know these are
fairly significant countries and bitcoin
is kind of right in the middle of the
pack of them okay so that means you know
proof of work is kind of wasting
hundreds of millions of dollars of
electricity every year some people would
say that you know visa is wasting more
money you know by existing then bitcoin
is on the other hand you know you can
still try to do something better than
than this and the main competing
proposal is something called proof of
stake and I think everyone here is
familiar with the concept it just means
that you should pick a minor
proportional to something that can't be
freely duplicated and instead of
computational power the currency itself
can't be freely duplicated okay so what
I want to highlight is a one specific
kind of approach so it's actually very
different than the BFT protocols that we
heard about earlier and this approach
basically says I like the longest chain
protocol I just want to update it to not
you know to not be feasible to have
extra computational power and do better
ok so here's just one sample application
so right you can think of a
proof-of-work has this stuff that you're
trying to hash and be small be like the
contents of the blocks and the idea of
the miner and you know this one time pad
and some other stuff that I'm skipping
and one sample proof of stake protocol
it's a strawman this is not a good idea
but what you could do is you could just
have stuff be say the current time stamp
and coin that you want okay so what's
the idea why is this not proof of work
well the idea is that it only makes
sense every time stamp to just do one
hash for every coin that you own it just
doesn't make sense to do anymore hashes
and bad you're not going to be any
better at finding valid blocks
okay so what I want to highlight is that
the main challenge I think between proof
of stake and proof of work is the source
of randomness okay so let me just think
about so for proof of work as long as
this H is a reasonable hash function you
got to kind of nice properties for free
all right so one of them is that the
next miner is unpredictable okay so even
if I know everyone who's mined in the
past whoever is gonna be the next miner
is completely independent of this okay
so I'm abstracting away the fact that
the hash function is not truly a random
Oracle but except for that it really is
truly independent of everything that's
happened previously okay and for proof
of stake it turns out to just be really
challenging to replicate this okay so
using this example as a strawman the the
sample kind of thing you can do is you
can actually pre compute all of the coin
x that pairs where you would be eligible
to mine if you own that coin okay and so
what you can do is now this kind of lets
you set up maybe like a really good
double spend or lets you be more
effective at selfish mining maybe you
just want to like sell those you know
you want to gather up all those coins or
something like that okay so this is an
undesirable property of the specific one
that I proposed and kind of what I want
to claim is that you know yes this is an
exceptionally bad idea but there are
formal barriers to using the blockchain
itself as a source of randomness it's
not just that you need to come up with a
better idea
there's really kind of a formal issue
okay so again in order for me to kind of
you know make any kind of formal
statement I need to just give some
simplified formal definition of what I
would call a longest chain proof of
stake protocol so I do want to quickly
disclaim this is a simplified definition
and there's you know there's other
parameters that need to go in here but
this is just to get the the main points
across okay so I would say a proof of
stake protocol should have two functions
the first function is a verify function
and that's what you probably have in
mind it takes us input a block it takes
us input a time step and it should just
say yes if that block is valid and no if
it's not valid so for example maybe this
function just says if the block claims
to be created at a time prior to right
now and the hash of the time step and
the coin used to mine it is small then
it's valid and if the block claimed to
be created in 20 30 I would say that's
not valid right now because it's not yet
20 30 and if the hash is too big and I
would say it's not valid didn't troops
take the second kind of function I'll
say it's called mining so what is mining
it takes us input some block a that you
would like to build on top of some time
T which you should think of as the
current time and some coins see that you
are using to you know quote unquote
proof stake and what is this gonna do so
it's gonna say if there is some block
such that it would pass the verifying
test and a would be its predecessor and
the coin used to mind that block is C
then you should output some block D
maybe equal to B maybe not equal to B
that also passes the verify test its
predecessor is also a and that the coin
is also C okay so for example if this is
the verifying function then one you know
what you should do for mining is you
should check to see is the hash of the
time step in your coin small and if so
you should just include all unspent
transactions and point to a okay so
these are just the kinds of functions
that I claim you need to define a proof
of stake protocol and the important
thing is I want to say that this verify
function should be computable and
poly-time for every one that's the same
as proof of work the main distinction
between proof of stake and proof of work
because I would say this mining function
should be poly time for whoever owns the
coin see okay so in proof of work
this is different in proof-of-work it's
computationally expensive to run this
operation and so that's why it makes
sense to have more computational power
okay but for prefix sake it doesn't
matter how much computational power you
have as long as you can run this
function which is probably time then
you're good okay so now let me just
describe with that in mind what is a
stronger selfish mining attack okay so
I'll call it predictable selfish mining
and it's an informal description
basically just because of this thing
that's in quotes but here's the idea so
you say okay look at the current longest
chain just like you would do in regular
selfish mining and what you should do is
just try to mine for all coins that you
own in the current time step you should
see if you can create a block once you
create a block you need to decide
whether you're gonna hide it or whether
you're gonna broadcast it okay and
remember we said the for selfish mining
it works it's really good for you if
when you hide a block you mind the next
one and it's really not good for you if
when you mine a block you don't mind the
next one okay and so the nice thing here
that predictability helps is you can
compute exactly because this is a proof
of stake protocol and this function can
be computed in poly time you can figure
out what is the next time step such that
you own a coin such that you could make
a block on top of this one that you just
created okay so you can do that and you
can do that in poly time because it's
proof of stake now once you know this
time you can say if this happens to be
unusually soon after right now then you
should hide it because you're very
likely to this is very likely to be the
next block that is mined and that's good
for you or if it's not unusually soon
then you just mined like normal okay and
so the idea is that again no matter how
small your stake is there's always gonna
be a sufficiently soon after now such
that it makes sense for you to hide it
now because you're right you're still
fairly likely for this to be the next
block okay and so again that gives you
the same kind of claim that says selfish
mining for longest chain protocols and
proof of stake creates a greater
fraction of blocks than being honest and
this is true no matter your fraction of
stake
okay so quick things I want to note so
it is not the case that just because you
create a larger fraction of blocks in
the longest chain that doesn't have to
mean that this is profitable so maybe
you come up with a different reward
scheme that makes us not profitable or
maybe it is a little bit profitable but
perhaps you can prove a theorem that
says for some reward scheme you come up
with you can upper bound how profitable
this is and maybe that's good enough and
the main thing I want to point out right
so everything I talked about you know
like there are some versions of these
ideas it makes sense for DFT protocols
but this theorem I said there's no sense
in which it applies to BFT protocols
right so it really only makes sense for
longest chain okay so I want to what am
I supposed to finish okay so I'll at
least pause here and just say that the
recurring theme from the first three
aspects is again repeat is using selfish
mining as a lens to analyze the
incentives in longest chain protocols
okay so again the things I would like to
distinguish is it for proof of work with
block rewards there were these theorems
that said that if no miner has more than
30% then provably the longest chain
protocol is a Nash okay so that means
that if you're only concerned with small
miners small minors cannot game the
system however for block reward with
transaction fees or longest chain proof
of stake we saw that they were
vulnerable to greatly improve selfish
mining attacks which means that even you
should be concerned even if you think
everyone is small you should be
concerned that even the small miners
might try to be gaming the system to get
an extra buck
okay so that's this thing I want to say
about this and then in the last five
minutes I'll try and quickly go through
one last result that's a little bit
different okay so the focus of you know
the last couple minutes is just you know
trying to understand why is Bitcoin
mining so centralized and this is
different than for instance being
support you know no one should be
surprised at visa is centralized right
it's it's directly in the code that visa
runs everything okay
but at least someone and I kind of
cherry picked you know this bolded quote
from a white paper that said you know
claims that nobody could have predicted
the proof-of-work would result in
centralized mining okay and the informal
thesis of the paper I'm gonna summarize
in a couple minutes is it actually
there's very basic economics that does
predict a proof-of-work was always going
to be centralized it's not just a
temporary State this is the way things
will just be
okay and let me first try and say why
it's not immediately obvious that this
would happen and again the key property
of Bitcoin mining is this proportional
reward scheme and one thing that's
really nice about proportional rewards
is diminishing marginal returns so what
that means is that if I fix the
computational power of everyone else
then the change in my reward as I
increase my investment in mining power
is actually decreasing right that's
because as I invest more in mining power
each unit of existing mining power
becomes worth less and if I already have
a lot of mining power then that might
not be good for me because I'm making my
own mining power worth less by
increasing the total amount in the
system okay so this property alone
actually suggests that mining should
naturally be decentralized this is a
really good property for
decentralization because it's not in my
interest to just pump up the total
mining power and make what I already
have worth less okay and this is
actually really good intuition so I'll
you know like prove that on a cup in a
couple slides but this intuition only
holds if all miners have the same cost
of electricity okay the other aspect is
that if the miners have different
electricity costs you should expect that
people who have less lower electricity
costs should choose to invest more in
mining and so now you have this question
of like okay if like what's more
important asymmetric costs or the
diminishing marginal returns and the
main thesis of this paper is that the
asymmetric costs completely dwarves
diminishing marginal returns so even
what seems like really tiny asymmetries
and costs turn out to be very important
in leading toward centralization
okay so let me just get the entire the
entire model up cuz I'll go through a
little quick now so it's very simple
okay so it's just that every minor has
some cost per unit of computational
power they choose how many units of
power they want to purchase that's the
entire model what's their payoff the
total reward is normalized to one
how much payoff do you get you get your
fraction of the reward and minus
whatever you paid for your mining power
okay so what's an equilibrium an
equilibrium is just that either your
marginal cost is equal to your marginal
gain or your marginal cost is greater
than your marginal gain and you chose
not to invest anything okay so now I
want to ask here are the kinds of
questions what are the equilibrium in
this game for different profiles of cost
and how centralized is it as a function
of the different costs so here's an
example I would like you to have in mind
say that there's a hundred miners who
all have cost 0.99 per unit of
electricity and there's a single miner
who has a cost of one I want to ask in
equilibrium what is going to be the
ratio of the investment of the cost one
miner versus the investment of the 0.99
miner okay so for example obviously
they're going to invest less but how
much less is it going to be a little bit
less maybe a little bit squared less
maybe like way less or maybe like way
way way less okay and so this model will
the analysis will tell us how to answer
this
and since I'm low on time let me just
get to the punchline so if you're really
good at math you can maybe try and read
through everything quickly but the two
things I want to highlight are that if
the costs are actually exactly the same
for everyone then you do get you know
what the intuition suggests in
equilibrium there's a unique equilibrium
everyone invests the same amount and
everything is perfectly decentralized
that's what you would like okay but it
turns out if we revisit the same example
then this theorem characterizing the
unique equilibrium says that actually
what happens is this single minor whose
cost is barely worse than these hundred
miners previously actually does not
participate at all in equilibrium okay
so again the main thing I want to
highlight is that this seems like not a
big deal right 0.99 versus one seems
like not that important but just the way
the economics play out it's a huge deal
and the amount of the mining power that
they're gonna have turns out to be very
different
no so people will still make money the
marginal cost is equal to the marginal
gain but all of the investments you made
up until the margin is getting you
profit let me skip this so there are
some extensions that you can ask me
about later and the main thing that I
want to take away from this is just
right so the not surprising thing is it
asymmetric cost shouldn't matter
I think the surprising thing is that it
matters so much okay and so what I would
say to take away from the take away from
this is that I do think this should be
kind of like a first order concern to
care about the economics of investment
in mining power or stake or space or
whatever expensive resource you want to
be using to drive your system and yeah
only the people with the lowest there no
one is know so what will happen so what
will happen is it if there's a single
minor then they have no I mean they have
no incentive to just keep investing more
and more they're already getting all the
rewards so the idea is there is this
force of diminishing marginal returns
that does say that in some cases if our
costs are the same or close enough then
someone else will invest besides just on
one person so the question is sort of
like do you get a lot of mileage from
diminishing returns or does it basically
just guarantee that there's not a single
miner and the claim is basically unless
the costs are extremely close together
basically all it guarantees is that
there's not exactly one
okay so let me since I'm now like a
couple minutes over time let me just end
here you can read this on your own and
ask many questions offline good
so the question yes good so I think so
one thing we did look at was the
opposite of that so we looked at
economies of scale and basically
observed that maybe unsurprisingly
things are you know even worse it may be
surprising how much worse they are we
did not look at we did not look at
complex costs but I don't know whether
that would like completely mitigated or
whether I don't know what exactly what
that would change but I think it's a
good idea to do
I had a question about the long-range
finding for proof of stake but I would
need you to go back and check when you
describe the attack or the check
the the selfish mining attack I mean
that's one yeah exactly
suppose and I'm not saying this is part
of your game but suppose I see the coins
of everyone that I can actually seem
like that's right before everyone else
in the game know when you're going to do
this let me just quickly repeat the
question so the question was sort of
like what if you can predict whether
other people are about to use this
attack because you can but you know you
can do this for anyone with any of their
points so the the easy answer I would
say is that I'm not trying to propose in
equilibrium I'm just trying to say that
being honest is not an equilibrium so
what I would say is uh that's that
that's the main thing I want to claim so
I I would sometimes would just say I
think that's an even stronger point
which is that in addition to being
honest not being an equilibrium probably
the equilibrium of this sounds very
chaotic and I don't know what I would
guess it would be
how about selfish mining as long as like
the blockchain keeps on getting killed
like yeah so if anyone else wants to
give a different answer than me that's
fine so but I would say the main reason
is you care about it in the long run so
you don't care about it right now like I
think if someone were to selfish mine on
Bitcoin it would not crash right now but
if someone could sustain selfish mining
on some cryptocurrency for a long period
of time they would get more rewards and
they're supposed to get they would you
know eventually gather up more resources
and they're supposed to have and then
maybe they would have enough to launch a
real like 51% attack so I would say it's
a long-term threat and also it uses
change quality like if you want to do
any close chain operations you have no
way to reliably like observe the state
of the other chain that you want to use
because the fullness of the chain just
goes massively up yeah so just I don't
know if that will get recorded the other
answer was that it does affect the
quality of the chain it's not as bad as
like you know like completely shutting
it down but it is not just growing
linearly like you would hope because
periodically you have these uh long long
Forks being revealed and changing it
that's bad I don't know if there are
other people with other other answers
too but
okay thanks
[Applause]